I my daughter who I haven't seen for a
while is coming today and it caused me
to think of an incident that happened to
she and I years ago here at Esalen and
it's a story which makes no sense
whatsoever but it really truly happened
as far as I can tell but it has all the
qualities that bedeviled this kind of
thing and what it was was I was as I am
now scholar in residence it must have
been some 10 years or so eight years or
so ago so clea would have been like nine
and I would have been 40 so we were both
younger and more naive and we it was
dinner time at the lodge and it was this
time of year and this time of weather
and the fog had been coming all day in
and out in the garden and it was and we
genuflect here God loved him to carlos
castaneda it was that very strange time
of day which only lasts a few minutes
between daytime and nighttime the crack
between the world I believe it's
interesting in in South America and also
in Hawaii at precisely that moment every
day there are certain species of
Lepidoptera that rearrange themselves in
other words that come out from wherever
they've been hiding for 24 hours fly
around furiously for five minutes and
then disappear again for 24 hours but
anyway it was precisely that time of day
and the fog was coming in and out of the
garden and we were not in a mood for
anything peculiar we were
intent on dinner and we were walking the
path through the garden and suddenly as
this fog moved and cleared coming down
one of the rows was a bunny a small
rabbit except that it it had very small
short horns now some of you may know the
creature called the Jackalope the
Jackalopes is the large Jackrabbit with
a pair of antelope horns and it is a
creature known only to exist above
certain low-class bars scattered across
California and Oregon it's up on the
wall the Jackalope it's something you
kid tourists with as far as I could see
this was a baby jackal oh about this
high and it it crossed the trail no more
than five feet in front of us we both
saw it and our attitude was not
amazement or an awareness that we were
entering into a paranormal dimension
both of us I think our reaction was come
and then immediately behind it was a man
a very thin not particularly healthy
looking man with a shaved head wearing
something like a grey running suit and
he was running crouched he was with his
arm hands out like this he was trying to
catch the the jaca bunny and when he saw
us he appeared very confused and stood
up and turning
and walked the other way and I just took
her by the elbow and I said let's get
out of here and then we went to dinner
and we've talked about it immediately
after and since and as far as anybody
can reasonably undi cently tell this is
the straight story on what happened well
it doesn't make any sense first of all
the earth doesn't move from its pinions
but what does it say it says that
attention falling into a certain place
of non attention is set up for something
like this to happen
and I don't I can't explain it I don't
think it's explainable it's sort of like
you know when you study quantum physics
and they tell you that a black hole
mostly puts out electrons but the theory
allows that it could be jekt Miatas and
grand pianos except that it would be
very rare for it to eject a grand piano
but the theory does not preclude the
injection of grand pianos so it's
something like that or it's a group
hallucination or it's a B which meant or
or or and it begins to proliferate I was
thinking about it last night or this
morning because I was in that place
where I saw it happen I was thinking
maybe maybe Esalen lasts a really long
time like maybe it's sort of like the
Piazza San Marco in Venice or the
Central Aryan Stonehenge
maybe we're actually starting something
here that will last so long that for the
next 5,000 years people will relate to
the Esalen garden
that somehow it's a nexus for others on
strange missions now the other thing
about that story that I like or that
relieved me as I guess the way to put it
is notice that it's absurd and by being
absurd its self canceling suppose
instead of a Jackalope which is an
absurd creature to begin with suppose it
had been a grey of the wrap-around I
type that are apparently trading high
technology to the government for human
fetal tissue those people then you would
have had a real dilemma on your hands
because greys are objects of cultural
fascination in other words if you see a
gray you just become part of a
statistical body of people who've seen
one and so it's like more problematic
it's not that it's a non reality it's
that it's a sort of a non reality this
is I think part of the clue to alien to
understanding alien abductions and the
way we generate information if I tell
you that I was up late last night and
couldn't sleep and walked along the
cliffs over Esalen and that I
encountered a shining disc and that I
then had and my navel lint was removed
by a team of extraterrestrial
cosmetologist this is evidence for an
already existing body of data if you say
well you should call MUFON they'd be
very interested in this or you should
call somebody else if I tell you I was
Restless last night and walked the
cliffs of Esalen and that I encountered
Bugs Bunny in the company of Patrick
Swayze
we'll just say you're nuts you know it's
not sanctioned it's not allowed and
nobody gives a hoot or takes it
seriously for a moment because it serves
no one's agenda it's just insane
data and should be immediately tossed
out this shows us you know that the
objects of in the unconscious are given
different weights and you can tell a
crazy story and join a self-help group
but if your story is too crazy
they won't have a group for you they'll
have a cell for you so it's worth
bearing in mind let's be generous here
someone had prepared a bunny with horns
to surprise someone else with whom
they'd had a lifelong running joke about
Jackalopes and they had arrived at
Esalen for the surprise birthday party
of this person and realized that the
bunny was frantic because it hadn't
eaten on the long trip so they took the
jacket bunny in its cage down to the
garden to steal some lettuce for it and
in the fog and in the effort not to be
seen the bunny escaped with its horns in
place and this person who probably
didn't have a gate pass anyway could see
the whole situation getting out of hand
and was frantically trying to capture
the Horned bunny and get it back in its
see people saying gee what a party
pooper this guy is well yeah but we're
trying to save the laws of physics and
the reason here for crying out loud but
I have to tell you that doesn't feel
right to what it is if it felt to me
like I don't know we all live in private
Idaho's and somehow I was in somebody
else's Private Idaho for a moment
against my will but I think we should
always prefer the simplest explanation
sometimes the simple explanation like in
a case like that is maddeningly complex
in itself but if you don't believe
that's what's happened well then what do
you believe do you believe that
mythological animals are potential
infestation problem in the Esalen
gardens or just where do you draw the
line
you